nice place what's up man it was good um
welcome to my house yeah good seeing you
buddy yeah you wanna come on I'll show
you around yeah perfect
[Music]
Brian Shawn thank you for having me in
your palatial home of course welcome it
reminds me of the Beyonce video you're
useful for some reasons well the reason
that we're here is to talk about your
new album and I think that a good place
to start is with the lead single yellow
right what's the significance of that
it's about identity specifically it's
about Asian tide in any but it's like
it's it's something that I think a lot
of people can relate to even if you're
not you know even if you're not Asian
and it's just kind of like because the
first part of the song kind of like
feeling suffocated and kind of like
going through the struggle and then on
the second part of the song it's like
this hopeful kind of feeling and I'm
just breaking out of it and it just
shows people that you know you can go
through struggle and just come out of it
in like a victorious way and it's kind
of me proclaiming that like you know
like yo Asian people can do this
and like I think that's really important
so I felt like I needed to do that and
then the name of the album is evocative
to the Sailor rise Sailor the Sailor is
me and like all the kids that feel like
they're very curious and very determined
and just kids who are explorers and are
not afraid to like explore just
uncharted territories and that's what I
was kind of trying to get at and you
know cuz that's that's what I am and
that's what I was and yeah and then it's
also just like it's also a metaphor
about all the you know immigrants that
came to America to live a better life
and to have this opportunity it's it's
kind of crazy like I realized that you
know I'm I'm I'm probably gonna have
kids one day and like I don't know where
I'm gonna have kids but if I do have
kids in America it's it's like I'm like
that I'm like that Asian parent you know
I mean that moved here and I started
thinking about all the Asian parents and
like all the not images Asian just like
Eddie
it's like it's a crazy journey man it's
just like I'm just kind of talking about
yeah the people that are brave enough to
like leave they're literally their whole
lives and like you know in their home
country to just move stuff somewhere
that they've never been before the place
that they don't know anything about yeah
it's a topic that you reference a couple
times in the album and I'll just point
to two lines one of them we crossed
oceans for a chance just to feel
something better
and then another got a full clip don't
even carry no guns don't need no I feel
like I'm 21 I know that you have history
with 21 Savage right of course he ended
up in a situation with his immigration
Stan yes I remember when that was
happening that was like that was like a
pretty like scary time like people like
it became memes and then you know what
people were laughing at it but like I
was like we're gonna my fall I oh
this is this is a pretty real life
that's crazy that is happening to a
rapper that is like famous as like
like what what's gonna happen to me and
I mean like who knows like what can
happen to me and it's just kind of like
it's it's a crazy yeah it's a crazy
thing like as an immigrant's like you
don't know like what's gonna happen to
you that's like one day I might not be
able to enter this country anymore for
whatever reason
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is the nicolaus copernicus room
named after the great astronomer and
mathematician nicholas copernicus
and this is where i write a lot of my
stuff what are you looking at
it's beautiful out here I can see how
you get inspiration I Ashley wrote two
songs off my album in here I wrote
yellow in here and then I wrote kids
yeah with a feather pen I can see that
yeah yellow I did it with the feather
pen and then kids I wrote it with the
typewriter because you know typewriters
are just faster and then when you're
really inspired you just want to lay
down that's ideas rapidly and I got this
on eBay um really cheap actually it's
$2,000 yeah and then this just shoot the
history video I'm this er yeah we
actually shot the the yellow music video
on this with the de Meyers um this is
the red dragon
first edition um they don't make this
anymore so can you not touch that thank
you
[Music]
when you came to the United States it
wasn't to go to college you know you
came and then immediately joined 88
rising and then became this famous
rapper right did you experience any
moments of culture shock when did it
seem totally different absolutely it was
when I first came in to a Trader Joe's
and then every single white person just
looked at me and then I thought I was
like oh I'm I'm in a completely
indifferent country right now and also
the first time I experienced snow that
was wild that was like that was
crazy was that in New York that was yeah
and then let me think another culture
shock moment I think when I went to
Hooters in a way I've never been to a
place like that
I don't think yeah I've never
experienced that and then I remember
first like landing
Miami and then this girl with like the
biggest ass just like came up to me and
then asked to take a picture and then
I'm like yeah sure that was like one of
the first photos I've ever gotten from
like American fans salute exactly and
then she and then she like did this so
my hair is like loosen it up here in
Miami now I'm like oh what am I
getting into right now but yeah that was
a yeah culture shock man most of it
though I kind of already knew what I was
going into because I'm like I've looked
at like America so much like through the
internet and just like I've had American
friends so it's not it's not as bad so
when I think of you I think of somebody
who has a PhD in internet culture you
know I know that you've been tweeting
since before you were 11 years old and
then of course we talked about how you
learned English through YouTube are you
still that internet guy I think so yeah
I mean sometimes I would go on like
periods where I just don't tweet
anything but I'm always just on Twitter
I'm always watching and that's what
people don't know I always like look at
every single mention that everybody
tweet sent me because I love reading
that and are you still on YouTube
I'm definitely still on YouTube I always
watch videos every day because like
right now I'm obsessed with steaks so
I've been watching this guy
Guga foods and I really hope he sees
this video and shots me out but I
love the internet man there's so
many like there's so much weird in
there and I'm always gonna be just like
deep into that
[Music]
yeah so this is a the piano and I write
a lot of my music here and what I do
most the time is I like to just press
random buttons in the piano buttons I
just kind of kind of press it until it
sounds like it makes sense and there's
this thing called the devil scale have
you heard of it no no it's uh it's like
a combination of like keys that was
banned
actually it was illegal for a while
because when people hear it it kind of
makes them feel a certain way it makes
them feel kind of like rebellious and I
guess the government we're just trying
to like keep people like the purge
outside exactly just like keep them show
but it's not illegal anymore so we could
play it would you like to hear okay cool
yeah yeah that makes me want to
commit an armed robbery too so I feel
like in a lot of ways you're
experiencing this contemporary idea of
the American dream
but I'm sure that it comes with its fair
share of sort of specific anxieties for
you like whether is experiencing Fame
leaving home feeling this pressure to
produce what are your coping mechanisms
you know yes right now it's cooking
steaks something that I've been doing
recently is I've been painting while
listening to Mozart on my Bose Bluetooth
speakers I saw my dad paints and he like
taught me how to draw as a kid so I kind
of have like well yeah I can kind of
draw so I just bought multiple canvases
and some paintbrushes and some paint
from Amazon and I would just like start
painting like when I have absolutely
nothing to do and I just feel like I
just want to feel peace for a little bit
I just like go on Mozart Spotify and
just like play the top five songs and I
just like paint whatever is on my mind
classical caviar exactly
yeah they should have that but that's
one of my coping mechanisms
I meditate sometimes I find out about
this thing called the tapping technique
so there's like points in your body it's
like it's there's like right here so you
tap right here and then there's a good
nap that can guide you through it but if
you typewriter and you're like you
address all the things that you're
stressed out about that day you're like
okay even though I have the shoe today
and I really don't know if I can do it
and I have to eat a lot of hot wings
I still haven't accept myself you know I
mean that's like part of it and then you
move on to like your eyebrow like like
right here it's like and then you say
like even though I hate interviewing
artists that I really don't care about
I still haven't accept myself and then
you move on to like under the eye even
though my watch is really nice but I
have a really small deck I still haven't
stopped myself then there's like right
there and then right here and then like
right here and then like on the top of
your head oh and then like the
collarbone but they're so these are like
kind of acupuncture points I think so
what happens when you do this and this
is like scientifically proven to is when
you kind of tap these points while
saying these like kind of nice things
and like addressing all the things that
you're stressed out about it's like
you're saying you're like thinking about
all the that stresses you out but
you're doing it while calming your
nerves so it's you're basically kind of
rewiring your brain and making kind of
like your brain associated this things
with like calmness and so you're
supposed to like think about these
things and like not feel that stress
anymore so I've only been doing it for
like three days I don't know so
yeah getting back to the music early on
in your career you'd have these comedic
references to money and guns or whatever
but then now the boasts are so specific
that I know they come from a real place
whether it's having a new home with a
backyard or being on late-night TV with
James Gloria and getting a new
grill yeah some of the highlights the
hallmarks of now like getting older
experiencing more success I would say
you know
in this house was like hallmarks and
this is a you made it dude I really did
this is really beautiful
and then like getting a sous-vide
machine
I started cooking stat like perfect
steaks with that
I'm the topic of steaks is this like
your gym rat protein intake or is there
something cathartic about cooking up
these meats dude I haven't gone to the
gym in like two months
honestly I wouldn't be able to tell you
really thank you I appreciate it but I
I'm obsessed with cooking steaks right
now at least this is my current hobby
yeah my whole thing is not even like
that I need to eat a lot of steaks or
protein or anything it's more for
security in my mind like knowing that I
can cook the perfect steak and like
every time just by feeling it and like I
have to do it like almost every day to
practice that you know I mean and it's
just like such a good feeling just
knowing that you know you're like that
friend that like can cook really good
steaks
I love steaks is its fire you had one of
the great hot ones quotes and we still
talk about it to this day and that was
when you said that cooking I want to
make sure I get it right
uh-huh do you remember this I definitely
remember this said let's say it at the
same time okay one two three cooking for
people it's just what if your thing to
do it's like saying I love you saying
yes perfect are you cooking for anyone
these days no I'm just cooking for
myself because I love myself yes
but I will cook for you if you want to
all right deal
so this is the kitchen where the steaks
are made well I know that you've been
checking out the YouTube tutorials yeah
on how to make steaks so take this one
away all right hey guys this is rich
Brian and this is how you make the
perfect steak today we have the ribeye
steak it looks like a choice grade I
would prefer usually more marbling than
this I got some kosher salt so you can
you know season the steak pretty
generously and it's like a pretty thick
cut so just make sure you you get this
tasting good so fun fact about the
ribeye steak this is the eye and this
right here it's called the rib eye cap
that's like the best part of every buy
steak and if you season it and then you
wait 30 minutes that's even better
because what the salt is gonna do is
tenderize the steak and you gotta make
sure that you get this garlic powder in
there two garlic powders my favorite
the Plautus thing because who
doesn't love garlic if you don't like
garlic
I'll like you so I'm gonna heat
up my pan and what I have here is some
olive oil usually my rule of thumb is if
the oil starts kind of smoking a little
bit that's like the perfect time for you
to put your steak in because if it
starts smoking that's definitely gonna
sizzle and you need that says
alright let's do this
ladies and gentlemen wait for like
season four minutes and then flip it and
then when we flip it we're gonna put the
butter in I'm gonna check and see if you
have enough press right now okay so that
crust in there
and then I'm gonna flip it over I like
medium where I think medium where is the
best way to eat a steak I know a couple
people that eat steaks well done why you
synonyms because when they told me that
they liked their steaks well down I've
got these buns with me I think it's time
to put the butter and so let's put a
whole leaf of rosemary and just take a
couple cloves of garlic and I just crush
it just like that
put this near the butter so you've got a
better basis bake with us as we do this
we can also start to put the steak
around and make sure that we get the
crust on all sides good easy on that
side it's very well that is what you
want to make sure that everybody's big
as a nice deer to it
yeah this makes me very happy this is
why I do this and I know I'm gonna take
the steak out and I'm gonna let us take
rest the reason why you want to let your
steak rest is because when meat gets
cooked it tends up
and it just becomes kind of tough and
when you let it rest you're kind of
letting the meat just kind of chill out
a little bit and it's gonna release like
all these juices what you're seeing is
not blood it's actually called myoglobin
and it's a type of protein so we can
wait like 5-10 minutes to let the steak
rest all right so that's how I cook
mistakes
well it looks amazing they'll get up to
try it out
all right so the moment of truth it's
got this open oh okay yeah yeah it's
like a cycle yeah it's like medium-rare
how is it that's a good steak thank you
I'm glad you like it
mmm it's got a nice sear yeah very crisp
on the outside
all right soft juicy tender on the
inside perfect
well-seasoned thank you do you see the
do this is what happens when you cook
with love garlicky buttery Oh yep oh
good good you did good thank you all
right yeah I'm pretty happy about this
you're proud of yourself yeah you should
be yeah so um yeah let's let's leave the
rest I am my royal tasters will be
coming in shortly the royal tasters yeah
the people that taste my food you want
to check out the rest of the house yeah
yeah
are you out there are you on dating apps
what's your what's your situation I'm on
I'm not gonna say what dating have
someone but I'm on oh like some when a
couple and I yeah cooking food is
actually kind of my move I hate
going out man I don't know why I don't
know if I'm just lazy or what but I just
don't want to like go to a restaurant
and meet somebody that I've never met
for the first time you know I mean I
feel like that's just like I would do
that with my friends it's cool but if
you're I've never met you before I'd
rather invite you to my house like
that's makes no sense but hey is this I
don't know it's just like a nice like
intimate experience and we you know we
could like go to the grocery store
together and get ingredients and then we
figure out when we want to cook and then
we like cook in my house and that whole
process I feel like it's so fun and you
could like bond over it's like a
team-building experience it's like the
foreplay and I think it's perfect you
know and it and girls live guys who cook
I think are there any parallels to
making a stake in making an album like
are any of those obsessions that you're
channeling similar dude what if like
that's true what if what if you're like
my therapist right now and you're
noticing these that I'm obsessed with in
my life
yeah answers that it's because I just
like love making albums I I would say
the similarities of cooking steaks and
like making an album is you if you sit
on it for too long it's just gonna taste
like and if you sit on an album for
and they just don't put it out you just
never just not good you're just gonna
hate it
mm-hmm even no matter how good it is no
matter how much you love it with the
first time you made it if you listen to
it too much like you're just not you're
not gonna see you know I mean ya know
it's the same with episodes yeah like in
the Edit on it or whatever you know you
have such a great experience in the
studio and then you love the raw and
then you're like cutting it up and then
the things that make you laugh like the
first 30 times you watch them yeah they
stop making you laugh and so you're
looking at this like finished product
and you're like wait a second does this
things suck exactly and then you put it
out into the world and yeah
and and you you only like hear people's
thoughts on it and how much they love it
and just kind of like wishing that
they're not lying that's art that's
basically art so this is my art studio
oh I like to paint pictures of dogs
these are actually all my dogs have
collectively about twelve and all these
dogs are actually from Asia I have the
Shiba Inu from Japan and then the
peeking is from China the kintamani from
Indonesia and the shar-pei also from
China and this right here is the still
work-in-progress I'm still not sure what
breed this is usually it kind of comes
to me right in the middle of the
progress but uh all right that's enough
for today
this is my name is Rory she's a really
fun cheerful dog
she looks fun yeah exactly but uh the
thing that I don't like about her though
she kind of scares the out of me
sometimes like at night I would be like
just trying to sleep and then she would
just like start laughing you ever hear a
dog laugh she can laugh dude it's
up and over here we have Satan
I named him Satan because he's a very
peaceful dog and his favorite thing to
do was play fetch and I would throw him
like a rubber ball some days he wouldn't
come back for a couple of days but then
he would always bring something when
he's back and it wasn't always the red
ball was it it wasn't always the red
ball usually would be human bones so
where's this collection going we don't
really Bay a bay it's gonna be it's
gonna be you trying to flip a painting
to make a buck absolutely it's gonna be
really expensive but you know
everybody's gonna eat it up so well what
are you gonna do with all the money that
you make flipping these on ebay more
dogs I'll just keep you anymore more gas
baby cats one day not dogs
so there's a lot more variation in your
flow and your writing in your tone in
this albums let me just hit you with a
few lyrics that stood out to me and then
you can pull back the curtain on this
okay this first one is the time flies
when you spend your nights in the West
End I didn't know that snakes come in
the form of a best friend which is like
a Drake level of angst damn Drake is
pretty angsty huh
Brian Thanks yeah I'm you know I'm
growing up and I'm like in puberty
as I go but I when I was right in that
line I was just it was it was over this
beat and and you'll hear it in the song
too but like it's like the most
aggressive sounding beat ever and then
it was like nighttime and I was by
myself and I was in an Airbnb I was
still it's I still didn't have my home
and I was angry and I mean I was like
what the
so I I asked started to talk about the
hotel the West End how great it is and
talking about snakes that are you know
that that that can be your best friends
but you don't know it and that's just
something that you learned when when you
grow up and you make a lot of money
you get this music industry is the
industry of the snake and the rabbit as
me Sean and Joji talk about like like to
say it's you can either be the snake or
the rabbit it's your choice you can
either beat and exactly one more for you
shoutout my parents my mother gave birth
to four winners all the players in the
game it's always cold benches what are
your parents and siblings think of this
career that you have I think I think
they're really supportive they've been
really supportive actually I'm sure it's
weird just because you know I don't see
them as much now but I think they just
like they know big the is and like
they they're they're just really excited
about everything which is such a I can't
imagine what it would be like if I
didn't have my parent
support like just guys you know it's no
matter how big your dreams ours it's
it's really tough right you know if your
parents didn't support you just kind of
because your parents is like means so
much to you you would just have that
kind of just like feeling like oh
maybe I'm not supposed to do this but my
parents were just nothing but supportive
so if you're a parent out there and your
kids have dreams
support it because your kids
will be a cool person like me I've been
such a cocky in this video dude
look at your house man how you supposed
to remain humble I supposed to remain
humble when you're living like this wow
this bathrooms sick dude Thank You Man
thank you um yeah these thoughts from
Germany the glasses from eBay
are you going to take a bath so
temperatures at this are you coming
[Music]
[Applause]
you and I actually crossed paths um I
recently in LA for a shoot and I think
now is as good a time as any to let the
cat out of the bag should we let the cat
out of the bag let's let the cat out of
the bag right we have a new season of
feast mansion that's right that show
where me and Joey cooked food with chefs
but this time is it's not just me and
Jody it's me GOG Nikki smoke came
through and who else came through I came
through oh you came through that's right
you came this time Melo of my brothers
oh and Chef Ludo came back Ludo taught
you the omelette the first timer yes how
was it hanging out the second time the
second time was was was great we were
making hamburgers and I think I think he
liked it he liked Holly chef
whoa he called me chef at one point he
doesn't just give those away from free
never having before on camera - well
you're only 19 years old you've touched
music you've touched hosting and then of
course cooking right what's next for
rich Bryan trying to be in a movie man I
just need it I just need one more medium
to look cool in you know because I
already have like music
and I have cooking but like being cool
in a movie is another level of cool I
feel like if you're like if you land a
role like nois Antonio just once like
you get a lot of Instagram followers and
they're all just like girls that love
you and I feel like I need that in my
life
so I'm gonna explore well thank you so
much for having me in your palatial
estate Reggie thank you I'm happy to see
that you're living big thinking that
you're dreaming big course you can you
can stay for however long you want
because so much space I'm like I
wouldn't even realize that and you're
here so it's cool
[Music]
what's over here this looks cool don't
worry about Darren so good let's
continue the tour
[Music]